so my perspectives about language have  changed significantly over the course of  this class I think in awakening me and  making me acknowledge biases and  perceptions that I had and trying to  recognize that all languages are equal  you know in thinking about other aspects  of my life where like you know wanting  as like a minority woman of color like  thinking of equality in that terms that  I never thought to apply it to language  and I never really considered how  important languages as far as like  identity and you know we learned a lot  about how in this class like language is  not just like their political social and  economic implications and so I feel like  this class has changed my perspective  and making me aware of those things and  realizing that language is important and  that idea that all languages are equal